this three metre fence was meant to
guard mexico's presidential palace from
protesters
on women's day instead it's become a
towering symbol of the violence
women here face these are the names of
those who have been murdered
because of their gender last year 939
were killed
between 2015 and 2020 the number of
women who have died for this reason
increased by nearly 130 percent
today we come to give a voice to these
women who are no longer here
today we come to write their names to
remember them so that they are never
forgotten
and that justice is done for them
in pakistan activists rallied demanding
shelters
to protect women from abuse around the
world
aid agencies say the pandemic and
lockdowns
have led to more cases of domestic
violence
women of course um during lockdowns have
been confined at home
so in the case of women who are living
with an abuser they are trapped with
that person and then secondly of course
it's been much harder for women to
access
services so some services have had to
close down during lockdown periods
or have simply not been physically
accessible for women
and we've also seen a very very
concerning trend of
increased violence online in france
activists rallied against existing
inequalities made worse
by the pandemic in the philippines
protesters blamed their government for a
rise in unemployment
and poverty the pandemic and government
restrictions
have made women more economically
vulnerable and added
to their invisible burden of unpaid
domestic and care work
our estimates show that across all
regions
women have become more likely than men
to become economically inactive
our estimates also show that women's
wages have been
hit harder so women's total wage bill
in the countries where we have data have
fallen by 8.1
according to our estimates compared with
5.4 for men
women have been on the front lines of
the fight against covert 19.
70 of health workers and first
responders are women
yet the gender pay gap sits at 28
the u.n says an equal future is within
reach
if everyone chips in but for now
it's largely women who are bearing the
unequal cost of the pandemic
priyanka gupta al jazeera